[Music]
in STFU news let me shut the [ __ ] up
oh my god
submitted by slap the base the moment ok
save the sound of a Stradivarius violin
a whole city must keep that sound like
ancient [ __ ] violin strings that
can't be ever made again it's the
[ __ ] violin that was made from a tree
during a very cold time of the earth and
the country down it maker a stratum it's
only there's only a few in circulation
yeah and they're worth because they had
like a mini ice age or something and
then it was it's not gonna be as cold
everything works better for acoustic
instruments I guess there was something
about the density of the wood yeah
during that time that ever made so
Antonio study very he he produced in the
17th and 18th centuries the [ __ ] top
[ __ ] hater right dude was born what
is that like three hundred years ago
give or take damn the old ass piece of
wood birth is only six thousand years
old that's a long way back there you so
in the city of cremona and Italy that's
where these instruments were that's
where he's from and these other two
craftsmen Cremona craftsmen they're also
very famous
Amati and coronary dead goose soot sorry
just slaughter that whole thing dude try
this just never anyone in America that's
like this was made by Mitch I know
[Laughter]
yes I'm do with a one syllable name
Mitch there's so old that they're like
you know deteriorating over time and so
eventually future generations will miss
out on hearing these instruments because
they'll just be deteriorated right yeah
but they have kendrick lamar yeah there
you go he's gonna die one day
so fact would his income and modern
science I'd say I've never done 200 easy
yeah either yeah so there are three
sound engineers who are producing the
Stradivarius sound Bank they're creating
this database database that they're
storing all the possible tones that
these four instruments selected from the
masala desert really knows collection
can produce your meds faces just all hey
Nate oh god damn it
cuz now we're still talking about like a
digital music yes we're preserving the
sound actual sound so what happens name
is here in it of course not but they're
trying to really do preserve it so they
had these four musicians playing two
violins a viola and a cello and they're
spending oh and they also have
thirty-two ultra-sensitive microphones
set up in this museums auditorium where
they're trying to capture the sounds it
would be about five weeks that the city
of cremona have to be completely silent
correct this sound better make me
tremble the ocean record this notion
makes noise to them the space the whole
town has to be quiet no construction
nothing you know Pablo stone roads
that's amazing I have rerouted all the
traffic to not pass through that city so
there's this one instance where this
barista in the coffee shop she said that
she had never spilled a cup of coffee in
her life but there's one day she was
wiping the counter and direct dropped a
glass and a police officer came in and
told her to like to be quiet because the
sound engineers heard it that
the whole time everyone's whispering
everyone's trying to take this sleeve in
the cop game with baby Salvatorian
that's good like it the acoustics in
this tutorial is like the exact sound
that they need like they really did
somebody's thought it just so happened
that of all the places on earth the best
place to record these things was right
near wherever they were made next to
cobblestone street looks like the
loudest place in the world risk
traveling cobblestone streets are the
worst [ __ ] thing to lug your luggage
over by the way private jet like you
totally rich traveling every kid with
the Rolly bag was [ __ ] with cobblestone
streets
I don't need stuff for our honeymoon we
were we went to Venice and then we like
fall it's either it's either get on a
boat for an hour or walk 30 minutes or
like we're gonna walk and it was like
cobblestones the whole way with I'm just
gonna find percent somewhere here has
Excel t-shirts and [ __ ] jeans in
Europe good luck dude I was bummed out
in France there's not a 200-pound man in
the whole [ __ ] country your mo eat
[ __ ] goddamn breathe yeah exactly
you're the only person [ __ ] in the
lift and you're squishy the lift how
fancy are you they treat it like it's
gold because it is 300 years that costs
more so we're like a million dollars
that's expensive and then this is
auditorium when they're filming you're
just fine and frog don't make sorry
recording thank you
why don't they just [ __ ] record on
and Riverside is not nothing going
that point in it's quite your
neighborhood Florida to hear their ship
tons of places where there's no people
because goes here tells me or Florida so
the reason why they didn't because this
is where they were created right this
auditorium that all these engineers like
they years like come up with all this
research of like where to do it how to
do this
luckily Ramona's mayor is also the
president of Stradivarius foundation so
that's how they were able to have the
mayor shut down the whole city that's
right we all love violence let's do it
we're gonna splash rightful that is
amazing yeah I hope that people 100
years from now like have a conspiracy
about it be like that G the G note they
play I'm real I know would they ever
really play it listen sometimes why here
this type of stuff like I wonder if
there are actual human beings maybe
there's a small select amount of human
beings that could tell the difference
between that violin and another one
right I'm not one of them yeah it's like
it's like a very probably very small
percentage of this world it's like that
[ __ ] with wine yeah yeah you give
them a decent wine in a really expensive
glass of wine that's aged around the
same time you give it to them and
they're like they could you know I can't
even tell two German Shepherds apart
sometimes sometimes I get them confused
that the mussel came back home with two
wrong dogs all the time we still
aggressive towards me
where do you think what do you think
happen at Tyson yes it's not Tyson yeah
I remember watching like a Mythbusters
and it was one of those that like if you
run cheap vodka through like a Brita
filter yeah keeps getting better right
yeah alright so like they did it like 13
distillation yeah and then also had like
a high-end vodka yeah and had some vodka
expert come on and taste him and he
[ __ ] nailed it why can't label them 1
through 13 and then picked the high-end
one was the only one he swallowed Wow I
was just like well [ __ ] me right small
percentage of this world
apart German shepherds know that be so
[ __ ] funny he's also colorblind he
could do that for vodka up of what the
German Shepherd egos like same dog dog
you can't do with any dog just if all
dogs are exactly the same all different
colors to you you know their water
Somalia Somali Tom one yay for water eh
there are people so [ __ ] canned air
there's nothing you tell the difference
of water though I think I can yeah I
mean like this is car Clem this is arrow
head you can already tell the difference
between like cities - like city wall
when I was in the great great city of
Fellsmere which is a fantastic yeah it
is there's like a population of like
2,000 people and 70% of them are Mexican
where where in Florida
oh they I traveled far I got it was like
this carnival there we went to a food
festival and then I had a piece of drink
of lemonade and I could tell it was made
from a hose Oh delicious hose water
plastic taste that I had so much as a
kid and I drink it us like sons of
[ __ ] huh I went to like a buddy's
house out here and the guys he's full
kook and just does that mean we just
fooled our business no like full bought
into like crystals and folly kooky yeah
he's your friend
yeah a hundred percent okay yeah he's
full cook I'm probably like 60 yeah yeah
a little bit over half I'm so like I
went in and like I went to fill up my
water bottle at his sink and he like
month like slapped it out of my hand and
he litter do not drink the tap water
because of the fluoride I got this and
like it has this [ __ ] glass bottle
and it has like geometry on it like
carved into it and it's a sphere which
is the with [ __ ] shapes
was the worst thing to pour out of this
is like reverse ionized and uh you know
it's uh you know it's been you know
alkaline your purified and it's been
structured I'm like [ __ ] that means
trust you leave you out the Sun for like
five days and like molecular composition
changes and like man I hope you don't
think this tap water is the least
healthy thing I'd do all day is lay well
you should look at the cocktail of drugs
behind
drinking hose water ma'am I got a bad
yarn like things are okay if you shoved
your hand in [ __ ] fish and pulled
them out that's not wrong either yeah
now my water thing got a lot of people
who's like it's like a huge thing but I
don't yeah there's like filtery out
flying waters [ __ ] the [ __ ]
bottled water industry is great yeah
because your body naturally whatever
balance itself out so it doesn't [ __ ]
matter who doesn't yeah so it's kind of
wild how big that [ __ ] got because he
used that's one [ __ ] doctor they're
like that's [ __ ] what are you
talking about it's like telling our
grandparents that like you know in the
future we're gonna pay for water in long
distances free yeah do you guys believe
that drinking warm or hot water is
better than the cold water that's the
agency the Chinese is the Chinese your
body's been landing Midway what do they
call it's hot food and cold food right
yeah Cheers
yeah yeah yeah okay cuz it yeah but I do
think like if you do eat something like
warm or hot it and all of a sudden you
need something cold it does feel weird
like in the stomach it's it's supposedly
like shocks my sister I think what's
more important is if you exercise every
day or not yeah if you like it hotter
like you could sit on the couch all day
yeah Ellie it doesn't matter what
temperature water it is but if you're
gonna be healthier if you exercise like
what percentage of health benefit are we
talking to focusing on like the way
wrong things yeah like the point zero
zero one meanwhile they're [ __ ]
hammering process like Generosa goes
great with all this bread that does
sound I drink hot water is my Big Mac
yeah it's fine do you it helps it helps
mellow you don't you have a [ __ ] cup
of ice this big and you fill it with
coke you son of a [ __ ] three drops of
coke in all this ice I love you I love
you
coke a nice hastaken that's cool a party
[Music]